26e édition des fêtes franco-écossaise
we have band français des parisiens est
lente et des bretons des berrichons
tous ont répondu présent avec même une
formation écossaise donington la ville
jumelée avec la cité des histoires qui
pendant trois jours un air très british
de saurik très scottish
c'est fantastique nous ne savions pas
que ça les lieux dans cette zone avant
d'arriver ici c'est vraiment sympa de
retrouver cette atmosphère familiale
alors que nous sommes ici cornemuse
bombarde des tambours font vibrer les
nombreux visiteurs sésame et visiteurs
20000 amoureux de l'ecosse et des
écossais j'irai ya 2000 qu'il te saluent
je n'étais pas content et je promets
mais oui à peu près 2000 qui certains
vous diront qu'ils viennent pour
l'histoire la guerre de cent ans
l'entente et d'autres pour le whisky
mais non c'est bien pour eux il y en a
de toutes les couleurs et de toutes les
sortes
on vient pour les voir on peut pas
l'éviter c'est incontournable
alors vous venez quoi pour l'équipe
tournait pour le whisky à ben pour tout
pour parce qu'elles sont toutes saoulées
kinta mais jusqu'à présent n'y arrive
pas ah non plus vous n'y arrivez pas nos
nuits fans aussi vous êtes arrivé vous
déjà on a essayé de vérifier pour vous
mais bon il était trop balèze pour moi
j'ai pas osé
voilà
à